we are committed to working with state
and local leaders to help secure our
schools and tackle the difficult issue
of mental health
prevention we have not done a very good
job of making sure that people that have
mental reasons for not being able to
handle a gun getting their name into the
FBI files that we need to concentrate on
that I'd rather pass gun safety
legislation than win the election we're
gonna find out what happened here and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
a real conversation about how we're
gonna stop it a lot of talk about action
today after that horrible shooting in
Florida yesterday 17 killed but what is
real and what could potentially happen
in the building behind us let's bring in
our panel Fox News senior judicial
analyst Judge Andrew Napolitano Jonah
Goldberg senior editor of National
Review a B Stoddard associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and host of No Labels
radio on a Sirius XM and Jonathan Swan
national political reporter for Axios
maybe I'll start with you what is real
you know Nancy Pelosi says she'd rather
lose the election and pass something
what's possible in this environment oh I
don't know what's possible because we've
been here before they didn't even get
bumped stocks legislation out after the
NRA supported it last summer we're not
looking at a real opportunity here both
sides continue to dig in the if you want
to actually change this you have to
actually take away the the weaponry with
the ability to kill so many people so
quickly that infringes on one
constitutional right if you want to stop
it's sort of get in early and screen
social media you're infringing where
people are describing these feelings in
these plans and intentions with
photographs and everything you're taking
away their constitutional expression of
free speech we hear what the president
says but behind the scenes what's the
administration thinking is there
thinking about a policy push do you
think well one advisor said to me that
this is you know theoretically of Nixon
to China opportunity you know Trump is
probably the only guy who could because
he's so solid on this issue the
anti-racism he could actually go there
but I don't think Trump wants
to go to China this is an issue where he
actually instinctively understands he
see he said it in speeches he says
Common Core bad Second Amendment good
and this is something that he is it's
internalized he's seen it on the
campaign trail he understands it and
there was nobody who supported him more
strongly during the campaign than the
NRA so I don't see Trump acting against
the NRA s interests on this issue here
is the president on making schools safer
later this month I will be meeting with
the nation's governors and Attorney
General's we're making our schools and
our children safer will be our top
priority it is not enough to simply take
actions that make us feel like we are
making a difference
we must actually make that difference
Jonah I think he's right and I should
also say you know I agree with a be that
we are at a political stalemate and just
the second this news broke I mean I
think everybody who has to talk about
these things professionally just their
soul just got weighted down just that
the prospect of the same arguments on
both sides which I think are valid
arguments and the important arguments
and all the rest but I do think because
if there is a stalemate in the political
system that doesn't mean that the rest
of society can't adjust to these things
there can be sort of an Israeli style
hardening of these schools there are
different tactics that people can take I
agree with a be the the if the
government gets involved and using AI or
something to monitor comments on the web
that gets into serious First Amendment
issues and we'll have him set his hair
on fire but the judge next but there are
you know this guy was saying he actually
said in a youtube comment section I'm
going to be a professional school
shooter right that is a red flag and it
was sent to the FBI so let's play that
special agent talking about what
happened there but the
yeah in 2017 the FBI received
information about a comment made on a
YouTube channel the comment simply said
I'm going to be a professional school
shooter no other information was
included with that comment which would
indicate a time location for the true
identity of the person who made the
comment the FBI conducted database
reviews checks what was then was unable
to further identify the person who
actually made the comment we do not know
if it's the same person judge
essentially agree with everything my
colleagues have said and my my heart
sank knowing that I was going to have to
talk about this because it's such a
tragedy and I like the Israeli model the
school doors are locked and two or three
of the teachers are trained to carry you
don't know which teachers they are they
do not carry openly they carry silently
and in a hidden way and how many school
killings are there in Israel
none that all can be done by the Florida
Legislature it does not require the
conference Congress can't do anything
Congress can't pass a budget Congress
can't agree on doctor we're going to
talk about that in a little while the
president I agree with Jonathan has very
much wedded to the NRA as is more than
half half the House of Representatives
that's a non-starter and there's this
thing called the Second Amendment which
they've all taken an oath to uphold and
the Supreme Court has interpreted as it
has at a very pro individual rights way
is the mental health push you know that
they're talking about this something
that they can get done with something
else and and at least around the edges
try to attack it well they've already
passed some legislation that Paul Ryan
pointed that out the 21st century cures
act that touches on mental health issues
I don't know because you're going to
have the left saying this is just a
smokescreen for the real issue which is
background checks everyone retreats to
their camps immediately and as a buddy
was saying it's very hard to see where
that common ground is this deal he gets
the ar-15 legally he buys it legally he
passes the background check
I mean something happened that is why
the gun control side will argue that the
that the background checks are not
restrictive enough that you are still
permitted to buy a firearm when you you
know I've been exposed have spelled firm
had problems and that and that they
would argue that if you can't drink
alcohol why are you carrying an ar-15
around at age eighteen one point I know
the NRA becomes like the shorthand in
these conversations but the NRA you know
if you look if you listen to some people
on some other networks they talk about
how all these politicians are owned by
the NRA you know we talk about how
Donald Trump is beholding the NRA the
internet actually doesn't give that much
money into politics compared to a lot of
other institutions their effectiveness
is that they are really and I'm a critic
of some of the things NRA does but their
effectiveness is that they're actually
organizing and communicating with actual
voters and that's what makes them it's
so effective I mean if you pull in these
states these swing states it's through
the roof I mean that's not NRA that's
that's not deemed by the NRA that's
being I'll be holding to the voters who
got you elected I gotta say that's
suggesting that this is a mental health
issue is a diversion it's an issue of
not enough superior firepower to stop
these killers if he's crazy he's gonna
find a way to kill
well he's rational and he wants to kill
he's gonna find a way to kill there are
300 million guns except in schools one
one white house is a sitting duck I was
talking to our White House senior White
House official tape out this and they
said what are we gonna do we're gonna I
mean there's whatever 320 million guns
in this country are we gonna do what my
country did I buy them all back I mean
this is not it's not realistic so I just
again I don't see this heading in a gun
control turret